l'europe on a vu des personnes gravement
blessées on a entendu aussi le terme
violences policières ce débat sur les
violences policières est ce qu'il a
toujours existé il a toujours existé ou
la première grande manifestation
parisienne du 6 février 34 on a même pu
craindre la disparition de la toute
jeune garde républicaine mobile dans la
presse s'était déchaînée sur ce qui
était réellement le noyau dur du
dispositif de maintien d'ordre à
l'époque
[Musique]
ouais
alors de la coop 26 et danger vent
particulièrement tourné sur le climat
comment répondre à nos besoins
énergétiques tout en prenant en compte
les défis environnementaux comme
d'habitude si vous voulez les coptes
sont des endroits où on fixe la date de
la prochaine coop des émissions de co2
n'ont jamais autant augmenté au niveau
mondial que depuis qu'on essaie de les
faire baisser aujourd'hui on a un espèce
de mots d'ordre qui est de fermer les
usines nucléaires mais sans penser à
comment on les remplace si demain on a
tous des voitures électriques on appâte
on n'a plus de voiture qui roule au
pétrole il va falloir qu'il y ait
beaucoup d'électricité produite et c'est
pas avec avec l'éolien pas d'énergie
parfaite on a été le premier importateur
mondial de gaz de schiste par contre
qu'est ce qu'on fait en france 24
[Musique]
devenez
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce lundi 24 novembre la
situation épidémique qui se dégrade en
france
affirmation aujourd'hui du porte parole
du gouvernement pour stopper cette
cinquième vague l'exécutif réfléchit à
une stratégie extension des rappels de
vaccins anti qu'ovide durcissement du
pas salutaire retour des jauges les
mesures sont attendues demain alors
faut-il sauver noël quoi qu'il en coûte
aux 2 au terme de restrictions on attend
vos réactions ce soir sur le conte
télégramme verte et france
la démocratie selon joe biden le
président américain organise un sommet
sur ce thème le mois prochain et fait sa
petite liste d'invités 110 pays et
territoires convié dont taiwan sont
exclues en revanche la chine ou encore
la russie le kremlin dénonce une
tentative de tracer de nouvelles lignes
de démarcation est de diviser le monde
on ira prendre la température à
washington et moscou qui a répondu suivi
en plateau de l'analyse de claude
blanche maison
au sommaire à 21h notre dossier consacré
au mal logement en france les expulsions
de bidonvilles plus nombreuses qu'avant
la crise sanitaire on stade un rapport
publié la semaine dernière par plusieurs
associations
nous irons justement la rencontre d'une
famille originaire des balkans dans la
plus grande précarité arranger un
témoignage poignant suivi de notre face
à face la france accueille tel
correctement les étrangers vous pouvez
réagir tout au long de notre émission
sur notre compte et d g
[Musique]
la cinquième vague de kobe 19
s'intensifie donc en france plus de 30
mille cas diagnostiqué hier le
gouvernement doit décider des mesures
pour endiguer sa propagation
des annonces seront faites demain par le
ministre de la santé olivier v rang on
retrouve notre reporter nadège à des
rasades devant le ministère de la santé
bonsoir la neige plusieurs pistes un
adage sont à l'étude notamment pour
inciter les personnes non encore
vaccinés à le faire
absolument et la première
piste vise à réduire le délai pour
l'injection de la troisième dose il
passerait ainsi à 5 mois au lieu de six
actuellement une troisième dose en ont
plus récents avaient réservé aux seules
personnes âgées de plus de 65 ans mais à
tous les français qui sera nécessaire
aux vacciner pour conserver leur pass
sanitaire par ailleurs la validité à des
tests ouvrant le droit au pass sanitaire
devrait être réduite à 24 heures contre
72 heures aujourd'hui des tests qui
devraient rester payant pour les non
vaccinés majeur le port du masque
redeviendra obligatoire dans tous les
établissements accueillant du public est
sûre elle est grosse manifestation à
l'extérieur on écoute à ce sujet un
gabriel attal porte parole du
gouvernement le conseil de défense et de
sécurité nationale s'est réunie ce matin
avec un cap clair que je veux réitérer à
nouveau ne pas avoir en revenir à des
mesures de jauge et encore moins des
mesures de fermeture de couvre-feu ou de
confinement dans notre pays des
orientations claires ont été actés ce
matin dans trois directions d'abord le
renforcement des mesures barrières et du
port du masque en intérieur comme en
extérieur l'aération l'ensemble des
mesures barrières qui permettent de nous
protéger vis-à-vis des contaminations
ensuite le renforcement du pass
sanitaires pour mettre davantage de
contraintes sur les non vaccinés que sur
les vacciner c'est notre logique vous le
savez depuis l'allocution du président
de la république le 12 juillet dernier
enfin l'accélération de la campagne de
rappel vaccinal
ces nouvelles mesures pour lutter contre
la cinquième vague de kovy 19 devrait
être annoncée ce jeudi lors d'une
conférence de presse d'olivier ferrand
le ministre de la santé a rappelant qu'à
ce jour un peu plus de 51 millions de
français sont vaccinés 6 millions
d'autres n'ont reçu à ce jour aucune
dose de vaccin et pourtant les chiffres
de contamination sont aussi mauvais
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne l'étaient il ya un
an alors que le vaccin n'était pas
encore disponible
merci nadège ad razak en direct du
ministère de la santé est à l'image de
la situation sanitaire dans le pays la
situation dans les écoles dégénère elle
aussi en l'espace d'une semaine le taux
d'incidence a pratiquement triplé chez
les 6 10 ans de plus en plus de classes
ferment leurs portes jean michel
blanquer un mini zoo l'éducation
nationale est pointée du doigt dans sa
gestion de la crise david khalifa
députés n'avaient pas forcément anticipé
le coc u19 ne touche pas seulement les
adultes les enfants non éligibles à la
vaccination pour le moment sont très
touchées par la maladie depuis la
dernière rentrée scolaire le 8 novembre
les chiffres sont sans équivoque le taux
d'incidence chez les enfants âgés de 6 à
10 ans a fait un bond spectaculaire de
près de 150% en une semaine il atteint
désormais le stade de 3 144% 1000
habitants alors que la moyenne nationale
du taux d'incidence s'élève à 180 pour
retrouver un tel chiffre il faut
remonter au pic de la troisième vague
épidémique conséquence le nombre de
classes fermées est au plus haut depuis
la rentrée de septembre
remontés les chaînes de communes de
contamination être capable de tester
c'est fondamental et ce qui est vrai
dans la société en général est vrai
aussi dans l'école en particulier et là
il s'agit surtout de l'école primaire où
nous déployons les tests les tests
salivaires c'est vrai qu'elle est
difficile au moment où je vous parle six
mille classes sont fermées et je
rappelle que l'année dernière au pic de
l'épidémie quand nous réussissions à
maintenir l'école ouverte nous étions
quand même à douze mille classes fermées
encore faut-il pouvoir aller faire ces
fameux tests salivaires et c'est là que
l'éducation nationale a pour le moins
flanché lancé fin février dernier le
dispositif devait atteindre 600 milles d
stage hebdomadaire c'est ce qu'avait
promis jean michel blanquer fin mai mais
nous sommes très loin du compte puisque
seulement deux cent mille tests sont
réalisés en moyenne ces dernières
semaines pour les syndicats la faute
revient à une organisation défaillante
c'est extrêmement lourd à organiser pour
les directeurs d'école qui jongle avec
les heures de cours les partenaires les
laboratoires se repose complètement sur
les instituteurs alors que cela devrait
être l'un verse ce n'est pas un prof de
toucher le matériel médical ou de faire
cracher l'élève ont pourtant la pression
est mise sur les professeurs par
l'exécutif pour faire monter des
chiffres parce qu'en effet l'urgence est
bel et bien réel hormis l'augmentation
du nombre de cas les hospitalisations
duo kobe 19 sont en nette augmentation
chez les élèves de primaire mais aussi
chez les collégiens cette semaine alors
quelle solution si le dépistage ne
fonctionne pas il en est une à l'étude
vacciner les 5-11 ans l'exécutif tarde à
franchir le pas au contraire des états
unis et d'israël la question fait débat
même si de nombreux voyants sont au vert
pour certains le recul est peut-être
encore on veut dire minimaliste
al'inverse très progressivement et bien
on va accumuler des données parce que
ben que ce soit aux états unis à cuba en
israël un nombre croissant d'enfants de
5 à 11 ans vont être vaccinés et donc on
va pouvoir voir un peu comme ça a été
fait chez l'adulte et bien les risques
de complications à mon sens ils seront
très faibles mais on va pouvoir mieux
mesurer la balance bénéfice risque moi
je suis convaincu qu'à terme la
vaccination sera rendue obligatoire y
compris chez les enfants car c'est
malheureusement la solution unique pour
pouvoir sortir définitivement
de cette épidémie le président du
conseil d'orientation de la stratégie
vaccinale alain fischer étaient
sceptiques en août dernier le contexte
épidémique relance le débat aujourd'hui
de son côté l'exécutif joue la montre et
veut voir les résultats dans les autres
pays mais le temps semble coupée au but
de la violence de cette cinquième vague
alors troisième dose de rappel ouverte à
tous ce délai de validité des tests
réduit durcissement pas sanitaire
quelles mesures pour endiguer la
cinquième vague en france sauver noël
quoi qu'il en coûte en étant toujours
vos réactions sur le télégramme d'ayrté
france place au décryptage
pour en parler sur ce plateau alexis
poulain éditorialiste à thé france
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous marcel
bénézet président de la branche cafés
bars brasseries du groupement national
des indépendants bonsoir marcel bénézet
merci d'être avec nous et on duplex
pierre tattevin
épidémiologistes chef du service des
maladies infectieuses au chu de rennes
bonsoir pierre tattevin merci aussi de
nous accompagner ce soir gabriel attal
qui a donc annoncé 1 3 pistes
principales à l'étude pour endiguer
cette cinquième vague renforcement des
mesures barrières le port du masque en
intérieur et en extérieur on y retourne
le renforcement du pain sanitaires pour
mettre davantage de contraintes sur les
non vaccinés et évidemment
l'accélération de la campagne vaccinale
il faut agir de manière forte perte
advint
oui je pense qu'en tout cas les deux
premiers pans de ce qu'ils ont proposé
la d essayer de faire un peu d'effort
sur les mesures barrières et plus
d'améliorer la couverture vaccinale avec
cette dose de rappel qui permet vraiment
de récupérer beaucoup d'efficacité du
vaccin est prioritaire pour le bas
sanitaire c'est toujours un peu dommage
d'être obligé de passer par les des
contraintes légales pour convaincre les
gens qu'il faut qu'ils soient vaccinés
mais en tout cas les deux premiers
pensons vraiment indispensable pour
essayer d'atténuer un peu ce qui nous
attend alors il faut faire peser la
contrainte sont les français qui ont
fait le choix de ne pas se faire
vacciner ans et gabriel al table qu'il
dit aujourd'hui
l'exécutif qui clairement veut inciter
voire presque contraint des personnes
non encore vaccinés à le faire alexis
blanc sel mairie tourments de la clarté
oui c'est ce qu'on voit dans tous les
régimes on a vu justin dardenne aussi en
nouvelle-zélande aux anges et non
vaccinés ils ont plus de droits et c'est
comme ça elle rit y est d'ailleurs
encore d'ailleurs à un gouvernement de
gauche c'est assez étonnant l'impression
que ce jeu là se joue à opposer les uns
contre les autres devant finalement
l'inanité des mesures la capacité de ce
gouvernement a géré cette crise il n'est
pas le seul dans cette une crise
mondiale mais ce surplace depuis deux
ans il fait du mal il fait du mal au
pacte républicain le conseil
constitutionnel a validé ces mesures
liberticides du pass à lithaire on
continue on va toujours plus loin avec
maintenant le bouc émissaire du non
vaccinés celui là qui seraient à
l'origine de l'épidémie sachant que les
vaccinés bien peuvent aussi transmettre
le virus est la question qui se pose
alors les enfants les enfants dès 5 ans
qui sont aussi là une poche épidémique
terrible hein on entend maintenant la
vaccination des enfants qui commencent à
arriver puisque aux etats-unis elle a
commencé les laboratoires comme pfizer
ont dit que y avait aucun risque on
pouvait y aller donc c'est un débat qui
va falloir avoir sans doute un débat
difficile je pense en france mais qui va
se poser puisque si on commence à
montrer du doigt le non vaccinés alors
les premiers ils sont 10 millions ce
sont les enfants de 5 à 11 ans on va en
parler mais on va d'abord regarder
alexis regarder ses réponses à face aux
pays européens qui font eux aussi
évidemment face à cette cinquième vague
je dirais que c'est encore pire regardez
l'autriche confinement total pays-bas
fermeture bars et restaurants ça vous
concernant marcel bénézet un bar et
restaurant à 20h01 slovaquie confinement
des non vaccinés tout simplement et
allemagne accès interdit à certains
lieux publics pour les non vaccinés
avant d'interroger leurs représentants
des restaurateurs pierre tattevin on
peut se dire que c'est encore pire dans
les autres pays ça veut dire quoi qu'on
n'a vraiment pas le choix pour endiguer
cette cinquième vague ces restrictions
qui peuvent effectivement choqué sur le
plan des libertés individuelles
on peut aussi voir une petite note
positive c'est quand même la france on
est parti de très bas on était des
champions du monde de l'hésitation
vaccinale ya encore un an dans une
campagne de vaccination qui est mal
parti et au cours de l'année 2000 21 on
arrive à des taux de couverture
vaccinale qui sont plutôt ou tout à fait
honorable et qui explique probablement
pourquoi on n'est pas des incidences à
1400 comme le tri genou qu'on n'est pas
si mal que ça alors qu'on partait parmi
les derniers d'europe en termes de
couverture fax alors marcel bénézet
quand vous voyez effectivement ces
mesures dans les
les autres pays européens
vous vous dites quoi bon pour l'instant
on souffle c'est ce qui nous va nous
tomber dessus et vous êtes très inquiet
on est très inquiet la profession est
très exigent était justement dans mon
taxi en venant ici vous rejoindre j'ai
eu deux appels de restaurateurs milieu
qu'est ce qui est ce qui va se passer
demain qu'est ce qu'on va nous dire
alors moi je leur dis surtout de
respecter de contrôler le pass annie
terre c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya eu des
réussites des relâchements il faut
reconnaître c'est même moi même allé
dans des restaurants où j'ai pas été
contrôlé et je leur ai dit en partant je
dis attention parce que si l'on peut pas
se permettre de refermer notre
établissement si demain on referme nos
établissements économiques communs déjà
l'europe les aides c'est terminé la
france peut plus se permettre
aujourd'hui on peut plus se permettre de
l'argent facile comme ça c'est
impossible donc aujourd'hui faut rester
ouvert par tous les moyens donc le pas
salutaire c'est un outil les gestes
barrière sénateur mais il faut contrôler
il faut contrôler sans cesse nos clients
des tirs entre faire demander le
contrôle du pas salutaire qui deviendra
passé vaccinale et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut coller les
français aillent se faire vacciner
la troisième dose pour ceux qui peuvent
la faire et se fasse faire signer
aujourd'hui nous avons que ça donc je
sais que c'est compliqué mais nous
allons encore vivre des des heures
difficiles des journées difficiles des
mois difficiles
noël approche et la montagne vous rendez
compte tous les gens qui vont partir
aujourd'hui la montagne et réservations
les gens comptait partir à l'étranger ou
partir en vacances qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire aujourd'hui il ya une inquiétude
et je vous assure et psychologiquement
aujourd'hui les français et les
restaurateurs mais des français en
général et même l'autre et même sur tous
nos salariés sont très atteints
psychologiquement parce que on est dans
une incertitude totale j'espère qu'on ne
fermera pas je souhaite ne nous rendre
ne ferment pas d'ailleurs alexis blanc
c'est vraiment ce que l'argument brandi
socialement le gouvernement l'argument
économique et quand on entend marcel
bénézet évidemment on peut quand même
comprendre à partir du moment où il n'y
a pas d'autre solution et c'est ça c'est
ça le problème c'est que on est dans une
logique économique de absolument ne par
confiner parce que de toute façon
c'était une erreur déjà tragique la
premier confinement on s'en est pas
remis en réalité on a fait une dette
phénoménale on a essayé de soutenir des
secteurs qui sont auto effondré bref
c'est scandaleux mais on a la même
logique que le tinal deyris nos
alternatives des néolibéraux des
thatcher qui disent on ne peut pas faire
autrement on a ignoré certains
traitements on a limité finalement la
recherche on arrive maintenant avec des
nouveaux médicaments pour traiter
précocement pfizer merck d'autres labos
qui arrive on a acheté très cher 170
millions le ban l'imap du laboratoire il
y dix médicaments dangereux et inutile
170 millions d'euros qui ont été cramé
en fumée moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
ya un vrai problème fondamental c'est la
gestion de cette crise en france
particulièrement sous le sceau du secret
défense il faut demander maintenant que
cette gestion crise soit collègues
collégiale qu'elle ne soit pas faite
sous le sceau du secret défense les
français ont le droit de savoir ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi des décisions un
patchwork de décision finalement sans
queue ni tête aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui dit on va
laisser les classes ouvertes on va
continuer de faire comme s'il n'y avait
pas de copine pour une certaine baisse
de la population et pour les autres
c'est la troisième dose ou plus de
passes ça suffit je croyais qu'on a
envoyé trois de voix c'est encore pire
dans les autres pays on confine en
autriche en slovaquie en gagnant
des choix mais est ce qu'on a le choix
aujourd'hui on a le choix puisque arrive
des traitements qui j'espère vont
fonctionner le vaccin on a appris tous
les six mois qu'il marchait de moins en
moins bien tous les six mois il sera
elle parle de quatrième dose faisant on
ne sera obligé de faire une quatrième
dose pour certaines catégories de la
population donc le recul on l'a en
avançant on n'a pas vraiment de recul
donc je croire que le problème qu'on a
avec nos gouvernants dans le monde
entier c'est qu'il n'y a pas de plan b
on a mis des milliards sur la table pour
un vaccin pensant qu'il serait à 95%
utile et qu'on met très vite derrière
nous ce n'est pas le cas donc on se
retrouve là sans plan b et il faut
bricoler avec les médicaments qui
arrivent avec les confinements les
mesures de confinement sur une certaine
catégorie de la population mais vous
avez des pays même vacciné ou savard
confiné malheureusement parce que on est
obligé d'avoir cette troisième d'autres
parce que même avec la troisième dose ça
ne peut ne pas suffire pour certaines
catégories de population donc on est
coincé par ce nom alternative donc il
faut maintenant je pense avoir une
gestion
déjà qu'ils soutiennent l'hôpital public
qui soutiennent les soignants ont parlé
en bien du mal parce que on à la crise
hivernale qui arrivent les bronchiolites
les urgences pédiatriques qui sont déjà
débordés avec les banques solides on a
la grippe classique on a toutes les
épidémies qu'on peut avoir plus les
traitements d'urgence avc etc qui arrive
donc il faut soutenir l'hôpital
maintenant c'est la première chose à
faire promouvoir les traitements qui
arrivent le plus rapidement possible et
si la troisième dose fonctionne faire en
sorte que tout le monde apprenne sa
troisième dose mais arrêtez de diviser
arrêté de finalement remettre sur les
autres son incapacité entend gouvernants
en disant que c'est la faute des
français alors que non c'est la faute
parfois des manades macron qui décide
seul sous le sceau du secret défense
alors on va regarder une première
réaction télégramme lily de la vallée
c'est le même discours qu'il ya un an
nous dit l inacceptable après tout ce
que nous avons enduré est acceptée
inacceptable avec un taux de vaccination
aussi élevé pierre tattevin c'est vrai
que ce message résume en lui-même
l'agacement de beaucoup de français il
ya eu beaucoup d'acceptation il ya un
taux de vaccination élevé et tout ça
pour ça
mais je pense que ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure et tout à fait vrai c'est
que ça serait beaucoup beaucoup pire si
on n'avait pas eu cette couverture
vaccinale combat actuellement et pour
revenir sur ce que disait votre
chroniqueur là on a essayé les
traitements il ya eu beaucoup de
recherche sur les médicaments et à la
fin de l'année 2020 le constat était que
y'a rien de très convaincant et ce qui
arrive va nous aider un peu mais ça
n'aura jamais les faits qu'on lui les
vaccins qui ont bien 95 % d'efficacité
il ya juste besoin de faire cette dose
de rappel pour récupérer cette
efficacité des vaccins mais c'est
vraiment ça la porte de sortie c'est pas
les traitements pour l'instant on n'a
rien qui arrive à la cheville des
vaccins en terme de bénéfice pour la
population donc ce que je dirai à votre
à lui de la balle et la cape à l'air
vraiment très agacé c'est qu'il est tout
le monde trouve que c'est inacceptable
voilà ça
serait nettement pire si on n'était pas
vaccinée et vous pouvez regarder la
dernière vague qu'on a affrontée au mois
d'août il ya deux endroits en france où
ça a été une catastrophe c les deux
endroits où il n'était pas bien vaccinés
on a réussi à traverser cette vague de
fin août en métropole relais qui veut
mon bien grâce à des couvertures
vaccinales qui était bonne là ça va être
plus et parce que c'est l'hiver mais
c'est quand même le vaccin la clé du
alors bien tu atteins juste un chiffre
que j'ai vu passer ce matin qui m'a
beaucoup interloqué 48% des hospitalisés
vacciner 40 4% de non vacciner à
l'hôpital
expliquez-nous parce que là j'avoue que
j'ai pas bien compris ce chiffre ce
matin
en fait on a actuellement en france chez
les adultes une couverture vaccinale de
90% donc le fait que les gens qui sont
hospitalisés pour un coût vite sont 50%
vacciner 50% non vaccinés c'est déjà une
preuve que le vaccin marche et parmi les
vaccinés convoi à l'hôpital c'est vrai
dans mon hôpital mais c'est vrai dans
beaucoup d'endroits la plupart des gens
arrivent un peu au bout de l'efficacité
de la du schéma initial c'est-à-dire y
sont à 5 3 à 6 mois et c'est pour ça
qu'on a vraiment l'impression qu'avec
cette dose de rappel les pays qui ont
commencé à le faire l'an d'ailleurs
assez bien montrer on va avoir une
réponse anticorps beaucoup plus élevé
qu'avec le vaccin initial avec les deux
premières injections et qu'on va pouvoir
protéger les gens mieux et pendant plus
longtemps et c'est pas très original
c'est pareil avec les vaccins diphtérie
tétanos polio hépatites ont fait une ou
deux doses ont fait un rappel quelques
mois plus tard et ensuite on est
tranquille pendant des années c'est vrai
qu'ils ont démontré un autre graphique
également qui monte quand même que il ya
moins de décès évidemment plus on est
vaccinés - il y adeux de décès marcel
bénézet
regarder oui ce graphique qui est quand
même parlant et en tout cas factuel vous
vous le constatez même dans la clientèle
il ya eu quand même de l'inquiétude ou
les gens sont abondamment revenus dont
les restaurants voilà malgré
cette cinquième vannes qui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on travaille on n'a pas de
veste il n'y a pas de baisse qu'il ya le
le contrôle sanitaire qu'il est qu'il
ira sur le fait qu on demande le pass
and it et rentre ça rassure le client
parce que vous assure quand vous avez un
restaurant si on vous demande pas le pas
salutaire vous avez des gens qui font
demi tour parce qu'ils disent ils sont
pas sérieux ils vont aller ailleurs donc
il faut demander le passage du ter
aujourd'hui c'est nous avons deux armes
la vaccination il faut il faut vacciner
vacciner absolument et le passé ni terre
pour nos établissements et surtout les
gestes barrière aujourd'hui on n'a que
ça mais il faut continuer à vivre
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui elle a
besoin de vivre les français ne
supportait pas un confinement c'est une
france il se redresse et ça s'est
terminé réel mal il faut vivre avec ce
virus s'adapte et bien sûr se faire
vacciner nous nous les restaurateurs
être très vigilants à ce que le passé
militaire on envoie des messages à nos
adhérents et on envoie sur facebook et
sur les réseaux sociaux demandez le pass
alité et soyez très vigilants l'état
promet déjà plus de contrôle de police
at-on raison bon je demande des
contrôles de police et que les gens
fassent respecter ce pas sanitaire parce
que il en va de l'ouverture de
l'établissement si ça se passe mal an
nous faire moi et j'en peut pas se
permettre aujourd'hui nous avons une
économie nous avons des trésoreries qui
sont out je veux dire nous servons pas
quoi il ya des pg e qui arrive à
rembourser mais c'est invivable c'est
pas possible aujourd'hui vous avez les
commerçants les restaurateurs et les
commerçants en général parce que moi je
suis un élu de la chambre de commerce de
paris ile de france je vous assure que
les commerçants en général sont très
inquiets par ce qui se dit mais si on
referme ce n'est pas possible on peut
pas enfermer lui il ne faut surtout pas
refermé il faut vivre avec ce virus se
faire vacciner appliquer le plan
sanitaire le faire respecter et c'est je
pense qu'on va s'en sortir mais c'est
vrai que les flux alexis c'est vrai que
c'est important ce que nous dit marcel
bénézet parce que là il ya une petite
différence avec la première et jusqu'à
la quatrième vague c'est tellement il y
avait de quoi qu'il en coûte
le chômage partiel là il ya plus de
mesures il ya plus mesuré catastrophique
il y avait déjà les peines vaccin donc
il y avait que ces mesures là pour
ralentir la progression aujourd'hui on a
le vaccin donc ce serait pas entendable
de dire qu'on va remettre un couvre-feu
remettre un confinement 1 ce sera un
échec total de la stratégie vaccinale et
de la stratégie sanitaire
inacceptable et pour le gouvernement et
pour les français donc évidemment il ya
quelque chose là qui ne fonctionne pas
on a l'impression de faire du surplace
depuis deux ans il se trouve que quand
même malgré la flambée des cas on n'a
pas une flambée aujourd'hui dans les
services de rémunération comme on a pu
la voir dans certains pics donc tant
mieux il faut continuer là-dessus et je
pense que il faut pas par contre là
c'est un conseil que je donne aux
gouvernements continuent avec la
stratégie de la peur du chantage de dire
attention si vous n'êtes pas sages du
rap à noël attention on va faire ça ça
ne marche plus les français en ont
ras-le-bol faut pas les traiter comme
des enfants je crois qu'il ya une
responsabilité
rés au sein de la population au sein des
professionnels de la restauration est
ailleurs les gens savent très bien ce
qu'ils ont à faire à que le gouvernement
arrête de nous traiter comme des enfants
à propos de noël on est dans le coeur du
débat je vous propose d'écouter franck
mates et un directeur commercial de
jouéclub évidemment l'enjeu est très
grand pour lui il exprime tout même son
inquiétude
en fait la question qu'il faut c'est
d'ailleurs des mesures sanitaires y voit
deux prises et qui vont contraindre la
fréquentation dans les magasins et
centres commerciaux on a vécu ça en 2001
donc aujourd'hui il ya toujours des
mesures de protection sanitaire qui
seront en vigueur dans les magasins que
nous appliquons au quotidien par exemple
chez le club le masque est obligatoire
pour les clients comme pour les vendeurs
et donc on verra en fonction des
décisions du gouvernement de quelle
façon il faudra que nous adaptons les
commerçants sont très attentif à ce qui
va être dit aujourd'hui la paix de
tester les clients et là que des
clientes magasin il ya une forêt de la
part de nos clients parce que des il se
projette sur une fête de noël qui n'ont
pas pu faire l'an dernier on a des
ventes qui sont en avance par rapport à
2010 lâche on est à plus important par
rapport à 2009 donc il ya de
l'anticipation et il ya deux favoris il
ya de l'envié et donc nous bien au
quotidien on accompagne tout cela pierre
tattevin c'est vrai qu'il ya de l'envié
on le constate certainement chacun
d'entre nous il ya du monde dans les
magasins souvent d'ailleurs un petit peu
confiné il commence à faire froid
l'épidémiologiste que vous êtes salles
inquiètes de voir toutes ces personnes
réunies en un seul lieu confiné
vous craignez vraiment la catastrophe
sur le plan sanitaire
je suis infectiologues ont fait un super
effet face à la récession
oui je pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse
attention ne pas faire d des
regroupements trop dense de populations
mal protégés et sans renouvellement
d'air après on la comprend la population
vient de vivre quasiment deux ans de
cauchemar donc il faut essayer de
trouver un équilibre entre les deux est
effectivement ne pas retourner au
confinement sur ces voix qui mettrait
les fêtes de noël avec la grand-mère nos
grands pères
comment vous voyez ça également quels
conseils
je pense qu'il est trop tôt pour se
prononcer la tueurs nés quand même un
mois il faut voir comment les choses se
passent on peut espérer que ça monte pas
trop et que ça dure pas trop longtemps
et qu'on puisse avoir des réunions
familiales au moment de noël c'est plus
d'un mois mais c'est vraiment trop tôt
pour dire on a eu trop de surprise avec
ce virus donc un mois c'est trop tôt
marcel bénézet
on navigue vraiment à vue au moins bien
ta devoir à la franchise de le dire il
ya vu depuis depuis deux ans maintenant
il faut apprendre à marcher en marchant
c'est le cas de le dire et qui aurait
pensé il ya trois mois il nous arrive
aujourd'hui à huit personnes même le
gouvernement a dit on y serait sinon
c'est aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous
voulez je vous dise on est devant un
fait accompli il va vivre avec il va
falloir se protéger protéger les autres
surtout et vivre avec ça et potable pour
pas se fermer ou à des comptes ccc sein
de l'entreprise les magasins ils ont
fait du stock mais aujourd'hui décédé le
stock est là il faut le vendre donc ils
peuvent pas se permettre d'un
confinement ni des réductions d'horaires
il faut travailler il faut nous laisser
travailler et il faut respecter les
gestes barrière la vaccination la
troisième dose les masques s'il faut
dans des écoles dès qu'il ya des
endroits où il ya beaucoup de monde
mettre le masque et on vend il faut il
faut travailler il faut rester et on
peut pas se permettre aux confiné
financier en main la france n'a pas les
moyens et les français sont au bout du
rouleau je vous assure que
psychologiquement c'était énorme atik on
va regarder de réaction celle de sandra
tout d'abord à le chantage de noël
sauver cette fête de quoi des décisions
politiques inadmissible et délirante
deuxième réaction de nico aucune raison
valable de tuer cette fête encore une
fois le monde a besoin plus que jamais
du message de noël il est romantique
sony qu elle ait kci poulain c'est vrai
qu'on parlait tout à l'heure des
hôpitaux c'est aussi là que le bât
blesse c'est parce qu'on n'a peut-être
pas fait le nécessaire
on a on n'a rien enfin ben on a demandé
à we be ségur de la santé pour colmater
les brèches pour faire que les soignants
ne partent pas en masse pour dire rester
on va un peu mieux vous considérez on
n'a pas
investi massivement dans les hôpitaux on
n'a pas eu le temps c'est arrivé très
vite mais on affermissent amélie en 2020
donc on a continué à cette idée de
l'hôpital de flux de la fermeture des
lits d'une logique finalement
catastrophique délétère pour l'hôpital
public d'ailleurs une manifestation est
prévue le 4 décembre donc c'est pas rien
ça c'est quelque chose je crois qui
l'idée aujourd'hui évidemment c'est
d'éviter que l'hôpital soit submergé
parce que chaque hiver c'est la même
chose depuis une quinzaine d'années une
vingtaine d'années avant le coc vides il
y avait la grippe chaque hiver qui déjà
posé des problèmes aux services
d'urgence là le danger c'est que c'est
les services pédiatriques qui sont en
danger avec les bronchiolites on n'a
jamais vu des enfants aussi jeunes faire
des bilans chronique on a maintenant les
services d'urgence qui disent on ne
pourra peut-être pas traiter des cas de
crise cardiaque d'avc parce que on est
bernard août on n'a plus les moyens les
soignants ne sont pas là on n'a pas les
mains qu'il faut l'alerté partout et on
a un ministre qui est surnage au milieu
de tout ça qui al'air obnubilé par la
vaccination évidemment il faut le faire
mais derrière il ya tout un système de
santé qui est en train de s'effondrer et
lui qui est en train de dire non tout va
bien on va rappelez-vous les annonces de
livres et veyran au tout début nous
sommes prêts on a vu on n'est vraiment
pas prêt et je crois que ça et cette
stratégie du chantage de la division
aussi de la haine envers les non
vaccinés qui seraient les virus les
enfants aussi qui font peur aux grands
parents il faut arrêter justement si
noël effectivement c'est un message de
concorde et d'amour il faut le remettre
sur la table on manque d'amour dans ce
pays il ya trop de maltraitance donc à
un moment il va peut-être falloir dire
il faut colmater finalement cette
division organisé par emmanuel macron et
dire ça suffit je suis présente tous les
français on a besoin peut-être aussi la
de se calmer et de dire on va faire un
effort collectif tous ensemble en
arrêtant de montrer les uns ou les
autres et de les monter les uns contre
les autres ce assez délétère ça c'est
scandaleux et c'est un coup d'épée au
pacte républicain pierre tattevin ça
sera le mot de la fin pour pierre
bénazet et pierre tattevin vous le
constatez vous cette situation de
craquage entre guillemets dans les
hôpitaux c'est vrai qu'il ya plus en
plus de malades d'ailleurs on sait
jamais trop quand on a le premier rhume
savoir sur des locaux vides ou pas c'est
c'est vrai qu'il ya de plus en plus
d'infections aujourd'hui vous le
constatez vous à rennes
oui c'est tout à fait vrai sky et alexis
poulain assez que l'hôpital est en
tension même avant le coc vide on avait
tous les hivers des moments où on avait
du mal à tenir le coup et est là c'est
un peu la cerise sur le gâteau c'est ce
qui rend l'hôpital public encore plus en
difficulté
donc il faut qu'on se serre les coudes
mais
ce à peu près ça peut pas être résolu en
quelques mois ce problème là il faut
qu'on forme plus de gens qu'on
investisse plus dans l'hôpital public et
malheureusement on n'aura pas le temps
de le faire pour les mois qui
s'annoncent
marcel bénézet le mot de la fin pour
vous est-ce que vous avez des prémices
de ce qui va être dit demain des indices
vous avez déjà j'imagine le contact est
peut-être le gouvernement faire une une
forme de lobbying de la rigueur de la
rigueur sur les passes annie terre bien
sûr sur les gestes barrières mais ce que
j'ai peur c'est les jauges parce qu'on
va commencer on risque de repartir dans
le schéma qu'on a eue de l'année
dernière et on peut pas se permettre
financièrement aujourd'hui nous avons la
profession qui est vraiment dans une
situation difficile et qui voit des
dettes qui se sont accumulés et qu'il va
falloir un bon c'est aujourd'hui non il
faut travailler donc moi je demande de
la vigilance de la compréhension nos
clients comprennent ils aiment d'aller
au restaurant qui se décrit sortie dès
qu'il arrive nous montrent leur
téléphone pour qu'on prenne le pas
sanitaires il faut qu il nous faut
travailler ils vont nous laisser
travailler merci beaucoup marcel bénézet
alexis poulin et pierre tattevin d'avoir
été avec nous en direct ce soir et
autres conséquences de la crise
sanitaire près de quatre français sur
dix ont vu leur situation financière se
dégrader pendant cette période de
pandémie c'est ce que montre une étude
de l'ifop et de la fondation jean jaurès
un rapport qui s'inquiète de la détresse
psychologique comparable à celle des
gilet jaune les explications de katia
technique le coc vide n'a pas seulement
entamé le portefeuille des français leur
moral la crise sanitaire a également
accru une sensation d'insécurité
matérielle chez nos concitoyens les
résultats d'une étude conjointe de
l'ifop de la fondation jean jaurès et de
lagence du don en nature réalisée sur
deux mille personnes viennent de sortir
l'objet de l'étude était la précarité
matérielle
les auteurs concluent que les personnes
les plus modestes ne souffre pas que de
pauvreté mais aussi de se sentir à part
des classes et ceci génère chez eux des
sentiments de frustration d'injustice de
colère ou de résignation selon les cas
considérons le contexte de l'étude elle
vise à comprendre les impacts de la
précarité des français et en cette
période de crise sanitaire
la fragilité est encore plus manifeste
en effet 36 % des français ont vu leur
situation financière se dégrader depuis
le début de la crise du coronavirus ces
résultats sont à rapprocher de ceux
d'une étude de l'insee faisant valoir
que près d'un français sur cinq se
trouvent en situation de privation
matérielle et sociale et ce malgré les
nombreuses aides et prêts proposés par
le gouvernement aux entreprises qui
n'ont pas suffi à consolider la
situation de tous les plus touchées les
jeunes les travailleurs précaires comme
les auto-entrepreneurs les intérimaires
et les ménages modestes leurs soucis
financiers entraînent un changement de
leurs habitudes de consommation
ils ont davantage recours aux hard
discount attendant les promotions sur
les produits qu'ils convoitent et
surtout il se prive de produits non
alimentaires essentiels jusqu'à quatre
fois par mois comme par exemple des
objets numériques ordinateurs téléphones
ou encore vêtements alors que ces objets
leur seraient utiles pour chercher un
emploi ou pour tout simplement
travailler ils sont dans une logique de
renoncement d'auto privations et cette
austérité laisse des traces en plus de
les handicaper elle génère chez eux un
sentiment d'éviction social ces
personnes en difficultés n'ont pas
recours au troc ou près où elle achète
de seconde main qui pourrait mettre fin
à une partie des soucis liés au manque
de produits car ils ont envie d'acheter
neuf pour se sentir comme tout le monde
cela finalement vient bien en écho avec
les demandes initiales des gilet jaune
qui plaidait pour conserver leur pouvoir
d'achat d'ailleurs un segment de l'étude
examine leur rapport à l'achat de
produits neufs légers les jeunes
interrogés expliquent qu'un objet neuf
peut représenter pour une consommation
similaire à celle de la majorité des
ménages français et la possibilité de
pouvoir consommer digne ces pourcentages
sont bien plus élevés que pour
l'ensemble de la population
mais d'ailleurs quels sont les impacts
générés par cette frustration ce
sentiment d'être à la marge d'être
laissé sur le bord de la route se
traduit-elle dans un engagement
politique militant syndical peut
nécessairement puisqu'ils ne sont que
21% s être engagé dans un mouvement en
revanche l'étude note que les français
interrogés se sentent gilet jaune à 16%
ou les soutiennent à 43% et que les
gilet jaune eux-mêmes vivent des
sentiments de frustration d'injustice et
de colère bien plus marquée que dans la
population générale
les auteurs statut que lutter contre la
précarité matérielle ce n'est pas
simplement fournir des produits de
première nécessité s'est préservé
redonner une place dans la société des
conclusions de bon sens mais qui n'ont
pas jusque là trouver beaucoup d'écho si
l'on en juge par les décisions prises
par le gouvernement pour restaurer dans
leur dignité et gilet jaune ou assimilés
à l'obligation vaccinale des soignants à
l'origine de la contestation en
guadeloupe à réveiller d'autres mots
beaucoup plus social comme la pauvreté
l'emploi et la hausse du coût de la vie
après une nouvelle nuit de violences de
porte parole du gouvernement a dénoncé
une minorité récalcitrante et violente
qui prend toute une île en otage des
tensions qui touche d'autres territoires
d'outre-mer les précisions de quentin
mauclair avec adrien fonteneau
aux antilles le constat est toujours le
même voitures brûlées routes bloquées
magasins pillés et des violences qui
n'en finissent plus en cause la
vaccination obligatoire du personnel
soignant et des mesures sanitaires
toujours plus restrictives parmi elles
la prolongation du couvre-feu jusqu'au
28 novembre en guadeloupe et après jean
castex lundi le ministre d outre-mer
appelle lui aussi au calme l'ordre
républicain doit revenir le ministre de
l'intérieur a annoncé des renforts
importants raids gign puisque la nuit ce
sont malheureusement des forces de
l'ordre qui sont victimes de tirs à
balles réelles et 7 cela nous ne pouvons
pas l'accepter nous devons le condamner
avec force car la violence n'a pas sa
place sur le territoire de la république
en martinique comme en guadeloupe
la contestation sociale ne touche pas
que le mobilier urbain les nuits de
violence ont été marqués par des tirs à
balles réelles des manifestants vers les
forces de l'ordre et pompiers une
enquête a d'ailleurs été ouverte par le
parquet de fort-de-france un
comportement regrettable mais la seule
solution pour se faire entendre selon la
population nous avons des points clés à
traiter malheureusement il en est la fin
du camp sans aller jusqu'à là
malheureusement on est des élus quand
même pour nous et les écouter ils n'ont
pas su attendre ce que ce que nous avons
à dire pas sanitaires
obligation vaccinale c'est quoi on a
plus de liberté chez nous ça nous on est
en devient violent voilà on n'a jamais
réglé quoi que ce soit avec la violence
là toi mais je pense aussi que je trouve
que si deux jours de lutte on va dire
mercredi jeudi et déjà vendredi là on
décide qu'il faut ramener du renfort en
guadeloupe il ya même eu une réunion
avec les locaux les le préfet ou une
réunion vraiment avec tout le monde et
que déjà on en voit déjà des forces du
gign plus de 250 gendarmes et aux
soldats et où on va où là franchement
depuis le début de la crise plus de
quatre-vingt dix interpellations et 60
garde à vue ont été effectués 26
guadeloupéens ont même été condamnés
pour certains jusqu'à deux ans de prison
ferme
dans le reste de l'actualité la crise
migratoire en europe avec un nouveau
drame dans la manche au moins 31
migrants sont décédés aujourd'hui dans
le naufrage de leur embarcation au large
de calais une cinquantaine de personnes
se trouvaient à bord le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin et est en ce
moment même sur place une réunion
gouvernementale autour du chef du
gouvernement jean castex se tiendra
demain matin le président macron promet
lui de retrouver les responsables
à londres le premier ministre
britannique gregory johnson a décidé lui
de convoquer une réunion de crise ce
soir
et la france et le royaume uni dans
l'impasse donc face à la crise
migratoire à la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne c'est aussi le
sort des migrants qui alimente toujours
les tensions au sein de l'union
européenne
les précisions de ciel bleu
le bras de fer continue entre la
biélorussie et l'union européenne ce
mercredi emmanuel macron a reçu le
premier ministre polonais mateusz mort
aviez ski l'occasion pour le président
français de réitérer sa solidarité avec
la pologne nous avons adopté des mesures
fortes et solidaire vis-à-vis des états
membres touchés par cette crise et ce
dès le conseil de septembre
et nous continuerons de le faire et nous
continuons à faire pression sur
alexandre loukachenko afin que soit mis
fin à ces pratiques inacceptables
l'union européenne de son côté accusé de
nouveau le président biélorusse
alexandre loukachenko d'être le chef
d'orchestre de cette crise migratoire et
brandit une fois de plus la menace d'un
durcissement des sanctions
nous avons pris une nouvelle série de
sanctions contre les autorités et les
acteurs biélorusse et nous sommes prêts
à mettre en place davantage de sanctions
contre tous ceux qui participent à ce
trafic d'êtres humains compagnies
aériennes aéroports agences de voyages
peu importants
du côté de minsk on s'impatiente
alexandre lukashenko pointe du doigt
l'inaction de l'union européenne
concernant le sort des réfugiés bloqués
à la frontière et l'accusent de refuser
toute discussion d'un judo korda
j'attends que l'union européenne
répondent à la question concernant les
deux mille réfugiés nous avons environ
2000 réfugiés dans ce campement je leur
ai demandé de les prendre
angela merkel m'a promis qu'ils allaient
examiner ce problème au niveau de
l'union européenne
ils ne l'envisagent même pas et même les
personnes de contact elle m'a promis
elles ne prennent même pas contact à
deux lits
c'est un dialogue de sourds qui
s'installe donc entre l'union européenne
et la biélorussie au détriment des
milliers de migrants toujours bloqués à
la frontière un rapport de l'eau a
jailli man rights watch fait état de
graves violations des droits humains à
leur encontre des violences mise en
lumière autant du côté biélorusse que du
côté polonais
joe biden à sa définition de la
démocratie il veut le faire savoir au
monde le président américain a invité
110 pays et territoires un sommet pour
parler de ce thème dans deux semaines
les principaux alliés occidentaux des
états unis seront présents les 9 et 10
décembre à cette rencontre en ligne on
en parle avec à notre correspondante au
m'abonner à washington bonsoir thomas
taïwanais est également invitée c'est un
message clair adressé à la chine qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas convié
oui on peut dire que la liste des pays
invités à ce sommet virtuel témoigne de
son aspect politique le choix des
quelque 110 participants elle n'a rien
d'un hasard taiwan en est l'exemple
parfait conviés à cet événement alors
que la chine elle ne l'est pas c'est une
erreur selon à pékin qui demande à
washington de s'en tenir au principe de
chine unique écoutez la réaction de la
diplomatie chinoise
la chine s'oppose fermement à
l'invitation faite par les etats-unis
aux autorités taïwanaises de participer
au sommet de la démocratie le
gouvernement de la république populaire
de chine est le seul gouvernement légal
représentant l'ensemble de la chine
taïwan est une partie inaliénable du
territoire chinois
quant au sommet de la démocratie nous
avons exprimé notre position à de
nombreuses reprises la démocratie est
une valeur universelle et non le
monopole de quelques pays conviés fait
débat puisque on peut se demander quels
sont les critères pour faire partie de
ce club où c'est finalement la vision
américaine qui s'impose une
différenciation qui nous ramène quelques
décennies en arrière à l'époque de la
guerre froide c'est en tout cas
l'analyse du réalisateur oscarisé oliver
stone qui s'est exprimée vous propose
d'écouter
je ne sais pas comment on peut défendre
une démocratie quand on contourne les
règles quand on veut quand sa relève en
fait de l'intérêt national
et c'est exactement ce qui se passe
c'est facile de dire nous sommes le côté
démocratique
somme le monde libre c'est de la vieille
propagande nous sommes le monde libre et
les russes et les chinois ne le sont pas
ainsi que les iraniens et tous les
autres du champ de l'autre côté ça ne
marche pas comme ça si vous avez visité
ces pays c'est relatif vous devez
comprendre le monde n'est pas noir ou
blanc il est gris
alors officiellement les autorités
américaines présentent ce sommet qui va
se concentrer sur les défis auxquels
font face donc les démocraties le
premier volet vous l'avez dit se tiendra
les 9 et 10 décembre prochain ce sera un
sommet virtuel avant une réunion en
personne qui devrait se dérouler l'année
prochaine merci te bats bonnet et pour
tous ces précisions en direct de
washington et sans surprise donc qu'un
les principaux rivaux de washington
pékin et moscou en tête ne figure pas on
l'a dit sur la liste des invités la
réaction de la russie ne s'est pas fait
attendre pour le kremlin les états unis
tentent d'imposer leur vision la
démocratie sans tenir compte de la
réalité les explications de notre
correspondant tu verras goffman dans la
capitale russe
une tentative de distinguer les bons et
les mauvais selon la vision américaine
c'est de cette façon qu'ils aient perçu
au kremlin le sommet virtuel pour la
démocratie organisée par les états unis
les 9 et 10 décembre prochain et auquel
elle la russie la chine n'ont pas été
conviés pour dmitri peskov porte-parole
du président russe washington tente
d'imposer sa propre promotion de la
démocratie qui n'a rien à voir avec la
réalité je vous propose d'écouter notre
attitude envers cet événement à venir et
bien sûr négative ce n'est rien d'autre
qu'une tentative de tracer de nouvelles
lignes de démarcation
nous avons lutté au début des années 90
pour réduire et supprimer ces lignes de
démarcation mais désormais
malheureusement les états unis préférant
créer de nouvelles et diviser les pays
entre ceux qui sont sur le bon et ceux
qui sont mauvais dans leur optique aussi
cela ne correspond absolument pas ce qui
se passe dans le monde
de plus en plus de pays choisissent de
décider eux mêmes comment vivre sans
regarder les autres néanmoins on voit de
telles tentatives de la part des états
unis ils essaient de privatiser le mot
démocratie autrement dit la démocratie
n'est que ce qui correspond à la
compréhension de washington mais
évidemment cela ne veut pas il ne
devrait pas être le cas et en fait ce
n'est pas le cas pour rappel les
etats-unis ont invité 110 p à ce sommet
pour la démocratie qui se tiendra en
décembre parmi les pays de l'ex urss les
etats-unis ont invité le cren l'arménie
et la géorgie la moldavie ainsi que les
pays baltes d'autres ex républiques
soviétiques comme la biélorussie et le
kazakhstan le kirghizstan le tadjikistan
le cpt ce temps et l'azerbaïdjan sont
absentes de la liste quant aux états
européens ils sont presque tous conviés
à l'exception notable de la hongrie et
on on va plus loin avec l'aude
blanchemaison notre expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claudes
blanchemaison un pays conviés donc au
sommet virtuel pour la démocratie
l'invitation de taïwan la chine et la
russie exclut il ya clairement un
message
le message c'est américain s bac et joe
biden se pose en leader tête de file des
pays qu'ils qualifient de démocratique
c'est donc une sorte de reconstitution
du leadership de la guerre froide et
d'une configuration de guerre froide en
réalité il continue la politique de
baden baden avait désigné l'ennemi c'est
lâche il et pardon le trump avait
désigné l'ennemi c'est la chine hebeisen
naturellement met en oeuvre cela en
essayant de rassembler une alliance
contre la chine qui est réunir est tous
les pays qui reçoivent de sa main
l'onction démocratique et c'est un petit
peu ça d'ailleurs la russie répond pour
le kremlin a entendu ce sommet vise à
diviser les pays il n'applique pas le
principe de réalité ce côté qu'à
washington de classe et des bons et les
mauvais élèves dans le monde c'est vrai
que ça peut paraître peut-être étonnant
ce côté un petit peu moralisateur
des américains notamment de joe biden
oui curieusement les américains n'ont
retenu aucun critère objectif
par exemple pour l'europe la grande
europe de lisbonne à vladivostok on
aurait pu recourir aux critères de la
participation au conseil de l'europe
conseil de l'europe comporte 47 pays
dont d'ailleurs la russie
l'un des seuls pays européens ou à peu
près qui ne participent pas au conseil
de l'europe parce qu'il ne veut pas
c'est la biélorussie donc la biélorussie
souhaite exclu c'est c'est tout à fait
logique puisqu'elle n'est pas dans cet
organisme mais pour les autres
effectivement ça relève d'un choix
personnel des américains et ça relève
aussi probablement d'autres d'autres
calculs et donc la russie se trouve ce
qui est un petit peu contradictoire avec
l'objectif premier d'encercler lâchent
ils se retrouvent précipités dans les
bras de la chine puisqu'elle est exclue
de ce sommet et je ne suis pas sûr que
c'est en réalité ce que l'administration
américaine voulait justement est-ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas intérêts comme à
une échelle nationale 1 le préconisent
certains candidats par exemple la
présidentielle chez les républicains il
y aurait pas intérêt plutôt à inclure
ces pays et alors parlez plutôt que de
les exclure oui je crois qu'ils y
auraient surtout un intérêt à se
concerter avant de faire une liste dans
un coin de la maison blanche sur du
state department et en effet les
organisations régionales auraient pu
être consultées g vient de parler du
conseil de l'europe mais aussi l'union
européenne parce que dans le fond
pourquoi exclure la hongrie c'est un
pays membre de l'union européenne qui
n'est pas sortie de l'union européenne
et bien sûr elle a des difficultés
actuellement avec le conseil de l'union
européenne mais ces difficultés sont des
difficultés internes qui doivent être
résolus à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne et ce n'est pas au président
des états unis d'amérique de décider que
la pologne participent et que la hongrie
ne participe pas une espèce poser la
question justement absolument absolument
et on peut aussi se poser la question
pourquoi est ce que l'union européenne
en tant que telle n'est pas invité elle
participe au g20 elle participa à toute
l'airé on international pourquoi
n'est-elle pas invité maintenant la
question qui va se poser c'est la
réponse des états membres les 26 qui
sont invités probablement puisque c'est
en ça n'est pas en présentiel ils vont
envoyer une déclaration
il est possible que la pologne
d'ailleurs déclare quelque chose aussi
en faveur de la hongrie ou que le groupe
de vie ce grade les quatre disent
quelque chose en faveur de la hongrie il
est possible que au bout du compte union
européenne en tant que telle soit aussi
invité et que monsieur charles michel
soit amené à parler au nom de l'union
européenne
ce qui est gênant aussi c'est que
probablement que ce sommet virtuel va se
prolonger on parle déjà d'un sommet en
présentiel dans un an mais la tentation
sera très grande d'organiser tout un
système puisque les américains veulent
faire participer la société civile
veulent faire participer les milieux
d'affaires et donc il va y avoir toute
une machine qui va se mettre en place et
la question se posera de savoir si la
france en tant que tel participent à
cette machine ou n'y participent pas
ceci fait déjà présenté très exactement
en
1974 lors de la première crise
pétrolière
lorsque les américains voulaient
constituer une organisation
internationale des pays consommateurs
pour faire pièce à l'opep à l'époque la
france avait répondu non seul d'ailleurs
à répondre non à cette question de 2 du
secrétaire d'état américain c'est juste
une question difficile parce que en
effet la position des pays européens
n'est pas de participer à une alliance
anti chinoises elle est d'être très
attentif de ne pas être naïf par rapport
à la chine mais certainement pas de
participer à une alliance anti chinoise
dirigée par les américains alors
dernière petite observation quand même
les etats unis eux mêmes ont rejoint
pour la première fois la liste des
démocraties en recul à lui fait
principalement d'une dégradation sur les
retraites en tout cas c'est ce que dit
un rapport de référence 1 publié par
l'organisation inter gouvernementale
internationale c'est cocasse quand même
c'est l'arroseur arrosé les états unis
qui donne des leçons à tout le monde
mais qui sont pas toujours
c'est pas grave c'est la faute à trump
donc ça arrange bien finalement baden de
m de charges et trump qui en effet avait
des comportements que c'est déjà le
gouvernement d'obama qui écoutait les
dirigeants européens n'ont pas cette
organisation internationales ont
qualifié dit libéral sur les écoutes
tout le monde écoute tout le monde vous
savez que ça c'est une autre histoire b
pour pour la effectivement c'est celle
amassée trump qui en est fait et est à
blâmer et ça arrange plutôt by donne
pour marquer marquer la différence alors
il ya d'autres pays naturellement qui
sont-ils libéraux et qu'ils sont invités
il y en a beaucoup tous ceux qui ne sont
pas invités dont certains sont des
alliés des etats unis ils le prennent
très mal que ce soit l'egypte que ce
soit l'arabie saoudite que ce soit
d'ailleurs la plupart des pays du proche
orient puisque au proche orient il ya
seulement israël et l'irak qui sont
invités et puis ne voulons pas choisir
entre le pakistan et l'inde vient de
bien le président by dane a invité les
deux
même si le pakistan est totalement dans
l'orbiel chinoise aujourd'hui par
conséquent il ya des contradictions
quand on analyse la liste des pays
invités et la liste des pays non invités
et tous ne répond pas à l'objectif
initialement annoncé effectivement merci
beaucoup que l'odeur blanchemaison nous
avoir apporté votre analyse
elles sortent de la liste noire des
états unis les farc est les forces
armées révolutionnaires de colombie à la
veille du cinquième anniversaire des
accords de paix qui ont mis fin à la
guerre dans le pays washington annonce
annoncé hier soir retirer les farc de la
liste des organisations terroristes pour
l'occasion le secrétaire général des
nations unies s'est rendu en colombie
antonio guterres s appeler à poursuivre
le processus de paix il a notamment
rencontré le président du quai et
l'ex-leader des farc
la base essentielle de la
réincorporation des anciens farc
aujourd'hui est que les personnes qui
ont opté pour cette voie sont désormais
couvertes et ont accès aux services
sociaux et à la sécurité sociale
c'est le chemin que nous colombien
devons parcourir nous comprenons qu'il y
à des obstacles que ce fut un conflit
très long qui a généré je le répète des
blessures très profonde et qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de malentendus et que
malheureusement ils ont essayé de
générer des matrices qui allait à
l'encontre de l'esprit de l'esprit et de
la lettre de ce qui a été convenu entre
les farc et l'êta colombien
déposé les armes en 2016 mais la paix
reste fragile depuis le début de l'année
près de 60000 personnes ont dû fuir leur
domicile en cause des violences et
menaces de groupes armés illégaux retour
en images sur ces cinq dernières années
[Musique]
où
mo
le
[Musique]
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du mal logement en france
les expulsions des bidonvilles plus
nombreuses qu'avant la crise sanitaire
nous irons justement la rencontre d'une
famille originaire des balkans dans la
plus grande précarité arranger rester
avec nous
[Musique]
non
le continent compte bien sûr quelques
femmes présidentes à son actif mais
souvent à titre symbolique à fiat et ben
bella ming êtes une femme politique est
ce que votre parcours a été semé
d'embûches ans ainsi que voilà vous êtes
là où pourrait elle
avoir les idées quand on regarde les
chiffres sur 255 députés nous n'avons
que fait le temps qu'ils sont élus les
femmes ferait mieux que les hommes dans
les domaines de l'éveil démocratique
lorsque les femmes sont de plus en plus
prises en compte dans l'échiquier
politique
ça traduit généralement un d'éveil des
consciences un éveil politique qui
bénéficie à la population d'une manière
générale l'éruption des femmes en
politique ça ne doit pas être qu'une
idée ça va être aussi un engagement que
le président ait
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure dont deux singes le
malheur c'est que quand on dit descente
des sages on a l'impression qu'on
descend des chimpanzés et pas du tout
les chimpanzés et nous savons cousins
germains maternelle qui était bretonne
me disais si toi tu es descendu sa joie
sur europe 1 a révélé nous un secret
vous en avez mangé du mammouth je me
trouve à fouiller en sibérie et puis un
bon matin dans le trou que j'avais
commencé à creuser je trouve de lait
tout comme ce quelque chose de bien les
grands en filaments je suis étonnée je
râle je dirais que ce sont des collègues
russes qui sont venus tripatouiller le
fond de ma recherche et puis à force de
tirer dessus comme rien ne venait je me
suis aperçu que j'étais sur le dos tu as
mammouth
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et d'aidé
de jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez
pas comment votre fils est mort vous
devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts ni
sur la bbc il réalise des hôpitaux visés
il était nulle part parce qu'on peut
vivre malgré cette douleur quand j'ai
écrit à la fois je souffrais parce que
ça me rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française allait aussi critiqué ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre et une
catastrophe est tout à fait les bras on
a vu des personnes gravement blessées on
a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé où
il a toujours existé ou la première
grande manifestation parisienne du 6
février 34 on a même pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine mobile dans la presse
s'était déchaînée sur ce qui était
réellement le noyau dur du dispositif de
maintien d'ordre à l'époque
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui ai des gandhi il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï et gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre dans
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire notre dossier consacré au mal
logement en france les expulsions de
bidonvilles plus nombreuses qu'avant la
crise sanitaire constat d'un rapport
publié la semaine dernière par plusieurs
associations nous irons justement à la
rencontre d'une famille originaire des
balkans dans la plus grande précarité
arranger un témoignage poignant suivi de
notre face à face alors la france est
kate elle correctement les étrangers
vous pouvez réagir tout au long de notre
émission sur notre compte télégramme
les expulsions de bidonvilles plus
nombreuse donc avant la crise sanitaire
les associations dénoncent dans un
document publié la semaine dernière la
multiplication des démantèlements sans
préavis le nombre de ces expulsions est
en forte hausse entre novembre 2001 et
octobre dernier + 30 % par rapport à
l'année précédente dernière illustration
en date hier dans les yvelines avec le
camp de roms de montée sont évacués par
les forces de l'ordre d'une quarantaine
de familles vivent et sur un terrain
désaffecté et des expulsions qui creuse
un peu plus les inégalités la pauvreté
qui galopent en france souvent qui
touche les populations immigrées ce soir
nous avons voulu nous rendre compte d'un
peu plus près de la réalité du terrain
dans notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous sommes allés à la
rencontre d'une famille originaire des
balkans qui fait face au mal logement en
danger des personnes en grande précarité
qui interpelle l'association droit au
logement qui se bat pour eux un
reportage signé guillemant aussi avec
alexandre lainesse
je suis dans le quartier de la roseraie
à angers où je suis venu rencontrer
gringo mariana et leurs familles qui
vivent ici sur ce parking d'un ensemble
hlm bonjour gringo merci de répondre à
mes questions est ce que vous pouvez me
décrire vos conditions de vie ici alors
nos conditions de vie c'est des
conditions très difficiles
parce qu on est avec nos quatre enfants
qu'on aura dans une caravane qui n'est
pas adaptée ça à faire en moins de trois
mois qu'on a fait une demande de
logement mais voilà quoi on veut pas non
vous vous êtes apatrides vous n'avez pas
de nationalité et c'est ce qui vous
empêche de trouver un travail alors que
pourtant vous recherchez bien un travail
mon rêve c'est de pouvoir travailler ça
peut vraiment nous sortir de là moi j'ai
fait une demande d'avoir mes papiers la
préfecture en fait me demander
des preuves de ma majorité depuis toutes
nos majorités en france et moi c'est
malheureux à dire mais je peux pas
trouver ses preuves la cua alors que moi
en fait j'ai jamais quitté la france ça
fait combien de temps vous êtes en
france
mes parents ont fui la guerre des
balkans
on est venu en france en 95 moi je suis
arrivé en france quand j'étais bébé je
suis français en fait moi je me sens
français à la base parce que moi j'ai
fait ma scolarité j'ai aimé tous mes
certificats scolaire en france la seule
chose que je demande de la france c'est
pas grand chose
c'est à voir mes papiers pour pouvoir
travailler pour pouvoir faire un futur
pour mes enfants faute
[Musique]
depuis combien de temps est-ce que vous
vivez ici avec votre famille quoi ici
sur ce parking
troisième mazet on n'a nulle part où
aller ce n'est pas qu'on veut rester sur
un parking on n'a nulle part où aller
alors expliquez-moi un petit peu comment
est ce que vous vivez ici au quotidien
avec vos quatre enfants dans cette
caravane
ben c'est pas facile en réalité parce
que c'est une caravane qui est prévu
pour quatre 4 personnes alors que nous à
l'intérieur on est à 6 vous disposez à
peu près de combien par mois pour faire
vos courses pour le gaz pour combien ce
que vous arrivez à obtenir par mois sont
100 100 euros par mois c'est l'aide de
l'état qu'on en fait entre les enfants
moi ma femme et mes beaux parents on est
au total vite en fait et je peux vous
garantir c'est que
c'est vraiment vraiment pas facile pour
la viande pour nous c'est du luxe en
fait c'est vraiment du luxe qu'est ce
que vous achetez en général quand vous
faites vos courses mais en général c'est
des yaourts pour les enfants
c'est du pin et demi on peut le
conserver c'est des pâtes en plus le gaz
le pétrole tout ce qui est pétrole on va
dire c'est le prix auront augmenté et
une bouteille de gaz entre 30 et 40
euros en fait ben c'est pas beaucoup
d'argent mais pour nous qui nous n'avons
pas de travail en fait c'est beaucoup
d'argent et vous allez faire comment là
du coup par exemple ben
là sûrement sûrement marianne en fait on
va aller faire la manche on va pouvoir
acheter une bouteille de gaz
[Musique]
djamel blanchard vous êtes militants des
quartiers populaires vous avez aidé vous
continuer à aider cette famille comment
est-ce qu'ils s'en sortent
solidarité qu'on a sur le quartier de la
roseraie car comment est-ce qu'il s'en
sorte mais justement c'est toujours
l'interrogation conte à chaque jour en
fait il n'a pas le lendemain s'ils vont
pouvoir être pouvoir manger à leur faim
avoir ce qu'il faut pour pouvoir se
préparer à l'hiver donc aussi dérangé
que habité de manière permanente dans un
beat alternative au tome une caravane
c'est un cas de la salubrité publique on
a une chasse aux pauvres qui est
effectué pour ceux qui ont le moins que
s'ils ont au moins acquis son billet de
trouver à d'habitat alternatif pour pour
se mettre à l'abri et on considère avec
les bailleurs publics hlm maintenant que
on doit chasser du pauvre con location
beaumont à une violence institutionnelle
qui s'inscrit à travers une audience au
tribunal qu'est ce qui leur est reproché
exactement à cette famille alors y'a
rien de délictuelles en l'occurrence qui
leur a reproché c'est d'occuper une
petite place de parking en plus de ça
qui est très discrète qui est très
réservé et qui n'étaient pas occupés on
en est rendu là quand même on l'a rendue
avec d office public hlm une mission de
service public pour permettre à des gens
qui en logements et en l'occurrence la
famille qui est ici qui vivaient sous
tente à la rue ont fait une demande de
logement on ne l'a rendue avec un office
public hlm qui se permet de demander 200
euros d'indemnisation mensuel d'une
place de parking c'est pour vous dire
pour moi ce que considère une extorsion
de fonds car avancer c'est l'escroquerie
et c'est pour ça qu'on ne doit pas
justement nous abdiqué se mettre à
genoux devant des politique nauséabonde
qui considère que des gens qui ont au
moins doivent subir le plus
et avant d'entamer le débat avec un nos
invités politiques et vous même un chers
téléspectateurs sur le conte télégramme
daté france nous retrouvons celui qu'on
vient de voir jean blanchard militants
du droit au logement arrangé bonsoir
gmail on a voulu vous réinviter entendre
votre témoignage en diète parce qu'on a
tourné ce sujet il y a quelques semaines
déjà pour prendre des nouvelles de cette
famille parce que c'est vrai que ça
semble entourer d'absurdité et surtout
beaucoup de misère 1,8 dans une caravane
est ce qu ils vivent toujours au même
endroit où vous leur avez trouvé un
endroit pour confortable
alors ils vivent toujours au même
endroit la difficulté qu'on a eu ça a
été que le petit bébé qui était
prématuré qui est en difficulté
sanitaire de santé il a fallu qu'on
compare au mieux et je salue d'ailleurs
un militant les activistes du dadt 49 de
la grande ourse des personnes 49 qui ont
permis à ce que ce petit biblique est
sorti de l'hôpital soit dans un endroit
qui soit un peu plus chaud plus
confortable que dans un endroit où les
femmes la famille vit actuellement c'est
à dire toujours sur une passe de garde
de parking et dans une carte il fait 3
fois d'ailleurs la nuit et il est muté
de gaz effectivement son ce vide très
facilement alors vous vous dites dans le
sujet on doit chasser du pauvre vous
vous parlez de violence institutionnelle
expliquez nous ce que vous voulez dire
ben oui ce que je dis c'est que
effectivement on a des services qui sont
très actifs pour essayer de trouver où
se trouvent des personnes en fin ou sont
des personnes qui essaient de survivre à
la rue et on a surtout d'un
positionnement qui est un positionnement
pour moi politique que ce soit de
l'institution municipale ou d'autres
institutions comme l'office public hlm
qui doit considérer qu'on a envoyé un
message vous aviez un sujet justement
sur un réfugié ont l' ange et un
positionnement rhétorique qui pour nous
est complètement stupide qui est de
d'éviter l'appel d'air et donc pour
éviter l'appel des arcs des gens
arrivent sur le territoire on ne fait
rien de mieux qu essayer de rendre la
situation très inconfortable de ceux qui
essayent déjà de survivre à la rue et de
ceux qui vivent dans la misère et en
cela on va pas hésiter comme l'office
public hlm qui est considéré
actuellement notamment pro délia non
seulement assigné en référé en urgence
une famille qui sont places de parking
comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure et de
demander le recours à la force publique
pour l'expulsion en cela il n'y a pas de
n'y a pas d'urgence pour t'en prends
propriétaire pour pouvoir essayer de
demander à ce que parce que les
personnes qui s'en s'ont petite place
qu'elle occupait soit sera donc expulsé
n'y a pas d'urgence il n'y a pas
d'urgence et c'est ce qui est grave un
petit peu c'est là qu'on n'espère pas le
temps à tous les collectifs les
associations de pouvoir permettre à la
famille de s'inscrire aussi à vous de
pouvoir faire un garrot on sait très
bien que les délais sont très longs ça
va jusqu'à trois mois pour pouvoir
essayer de disposer d'un hébergement ça
peut aller jusqu'à six mois dans le cas
d'un dalot pour essayer d'obtenir un
logement en l'occurrence la famille
demander un logement donc on ne laisse
même pas le temps aux personnes de se
retourner et en cela je dis que cette
violence déjà dans la misère que la
famille subit s'ajoute la violence
institutionnelle puisque on a vu parfois
des policiers essayé de déloger les
personnes qui étaient quittés l'an
situation très précaire donc en
l'occurrence en mitri de la loi et ont
redonné mois maintenant on a compris en
tout cas de message mais nous sommes en
campagne présidentielle vous avez
notamment sur ce plateau qui vient de
nous rejoindre un pape parle de xavier
bertrand si vous avez un message à
passer au candidat lequel
s
alors le message est simple soit il ment
arrêtez vos démagogie vous discours de
bla bla bla pour essayer de rassurer un
campus qu'un autre et favoriser un
groupe puisque nous c'est une violence
de classe qui est inacceptable on arrête
stop ont fait l'humanité et la
convention des droits de l'homme et à la
convention des droits de l'enfant on les
applique on est respectueux des
conventions internationales qui
permettent aux gens de retrouver un
petit peu plus de dignité voilà c'est le
seul message que je peux leur donner
avec tous les collectifs les autres
associations essayez de ne pas utiliser
votre pouvoir et vos moyens pour essayer
de casser des gens alors que ces gens là
ont déjà subi plus que pourrait subir la
misère toute entière de de l'humanité
merci beaucoup djamel blanchard un
militant d'al 49 d'avoir été avec nous
et le thème de l'immigration est présent
on l'a constaté dans la campagne depuis
déjà plusieurs semaines ce soir nous
avons voulu le traiter différemment la
france accueille tel correctement les
étrangers on vous donne la parole sur le
conte télégramme berthet france et c'est
l'objet de notre face à face
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
jean didier berthault porte parole de
xavier bertrand dont car je le disais
qu'il nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
candidat à la primaire en l air pour la
présidentielle 2022 je parle évidemment
de xavier bertrand pas de vous et les
bons soirs et merci d'être là yves
contassot membre d'europe écologie les
verts vous êtes vous en direct par skype
avec nous ce soir merci à vous d'être là
rameau tout d'abord sur notre
reportage un gringo le père de famille
nous dit mon rêve c'est de travailler il
rêve d'un futur clairement avec ses
enfants
et à la place il vit vous l'avez vu dans
une caravane à 8 et il vit surtout un
enfer bureaucratique qu'on a du mal
c'est vrai à comprendre qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire yves contassot
écoutez moi ce que je vois c'est que je
prends la situation parisienne par
exemple ça fait des mois et des mois que
les personnes essayent en vain d'avoir
un rendez vous avec la préfecture de
police pour que leur dossier soit
simplement examiné
c'est un traitement que je n'ai jamais
vu jamais vu ça fait plus de vingt ans
que je m'occupe de de ces questions
d'immigration de régularisation je n'ai
jamais vu une telle inhumanité les gens
sont dehors on les envoie vers des
d'espèces de camions qui sont là des
camionnettes où on leur disait essayé
sur internet à l'option internet il a
absolument aucune connexion possible on
les renvoie de semaine en semaine et à
personne pour simplement examiner leurs
dossiers or s'il ya des gens qui de
toute évidence ne seront peut-être pas
régularisée d'autres ont parfaitement le
droit d'être régularisés et pour autant
personne personne n'est en capacité de
les accueillir on voit à quel point il
ya une volonté de ne presque de
stigmatisation de vexations de
traitement inhumain c'est vraiment
scandaleux et sa déshonore le pays qui
se targue d'être le pays des droits de
l'homme par jean didier berthault dans
ce cas est un cas un petit peu
particulier parce que ce père de famille
et apatrides en guerre des balkans mais
enfin c'est vrai qu'il est ni français
ni rien du tout et on le laisse un petit
peu livré à son sort est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
il ya une forme de stigmatisation de ces
personnes qu'on laisse sans même traiter
leurs dossiers il ya visiblement
effectivement comme l'a dit yves
contassot une question et d'inhumanité
mais pourquoi avoir de l'humanité il
faut qu'il y ait des règles et le
problème c'est que dans un pays où il
n'y a plus de règle dans un pays où ne
contrôle plus on ne maîtrise plus les
frontières où on laisse les situation
dégénérer comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
forcément on arrive à des situations qui
deviennent critiques on l'a encore vu ce
soir avec un un bateau et trente et une
victimes dans la manche c'est
inacceptable c'est révoltant mais ceux
qui sont responsables de cela c'est ce
qu'ils ont laissé faire le fait que l'on
ne maîtrise plus nos frontières et tout
le problème est là c'est d'avoir aussi
la fermeté nécessaire pour que ces
frontières une fois maîtrisé on puisse
est effectivement traitées avec humanité
ceux qui ont le droit de rester sur le
sol français mais le problème il est là
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est aujourd'hui
plus en capacité de faire cette
distinction est que l'on se retrouve
face à cette situation dramatique et
face à des filières qui s'organise et
qui vivent sur la misère des gens yves
contassot effectivement sur cette
capacité
ça revient souvent nous ne sommes plus
en capacité
d'accueillir et de gérer l'état se
retrouve peut-être un puissant tout
simplement dépassé
côté il faut pas se raconter d'histoires
on est en campagne électorale alors les
républicains ont choisi
d'instrumentaliser la question de
l'immigration en courant après les voix
des de marine le pen et d'eric zemmour
mais la réalité est très différente
on peut prendre quelques exemples le
stade de france a été quasiment
exclusivement construit par des sans
papiers aujourd'hui tous les jours tous
les jours je croise des gens qui sont
sans papiers et qui sont employés par
des entreprises qui savent parfaitement
qu'ils sont sans papiers et pourquoi
parce que ça leur permet de ne pas payer
un certain nombre de taxes ne pas payer
des impôts de ne pas garantir la
sécurité des personnes et donc tout ça
est d'une hypocrisie absolue et c'est
connu évidemment des de tous les
responsables politiques donc on n'est
pas du tout dans une situation de nos
contrôles on est dans une situation
volontairement on ferme les yeux sur un
certain nombre de malversations de
réseau on l'a vu alors malheureusement
est ce qui s'est passé en biélorussie où
ils compris des états instrumentalise la
question de l'immigration et l'europe
choisi il faut le dire de délayer à
certains pays la question de
l'immigration que ce soit de manière un
peu officiel avec la turquie et en
payant très cher pour ça ou bien de
manière alors beaucoup moins officielle
est beaucoup moins humaine vis-à-vis de
l'italie où d'autres pays qui sont aux
premières loges de la question de
l'immigration et c'est pas en fermant
nos frontières qu'on réglera la question
on le voit bien il suffit d'aller à
calais c'est pas la frontière française
qui est fermé c'est la frontière
anglaise et donc c'est pas du tout comme
ça qu'on va régler la question j'ajoute
le dernier point c'est que on parle
toujours de l'immigration on oublie de
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de français qui
vont travailler à l'étranger et que dit
on à ces français vous ne devriez pas
partir à l'étranger vous devriez rester
travailler en france là comme par hasard
on ne dit rien on considère que cette
émigration là elle est acceptable mais
que dans l'autre sens ça ne l'est pas
jean didier berthault
la réponse à yves contassot ya une forme
de double langage et notamment en
période électorale écoutez la période
électorale oui elle existe après yves
contassot aura quand même du mal à me
faire croire que lui aussi n'est pas en
campagne électorale pour pour ses
propres idées donc je peux pas laisser
dire qu'il ya une instrumentalisation
sur un sujet aussi grave le sujet il est
de reprendre la maîtrise de nos
frontières et d'avoir des d'avoir des
mesures qui sont des mesures concrètes
quand en novembre quand en novembre 2012
après le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
la circulaire a permis des
régularisations et que nous avons
aujourd'hui trente mille régularisation
qui sont à peu près annuel cette
circulaire il faut aujourd'hui l'abroger
il faut traiter du cas par cas on voit
bien aujourd'hui que on n'a pas les
moyens de mener la même politique
migratoire que celle qui a été menée
depuis des années donc soit on prend des
mesures soit on continue à favoriser un
terreau qui sera propice aux extrêmes je
crois que ce n'est ni la volonté des
républicains ni celle de monsieur
contassot donc c'est à nous aussi de
prendre nos responsabilités mais il faut
les prendre aussi de façon lucide
visiblement ce manque de lucidité
aujourd'hui d'une certaine partie de la
gauche nous le payons cher parce que ça
fait dix ans aujourd'hui que cette
dérive existe on va regarder une des
premières réactions télégramme celle de
laurent fortier on confond droit d'asile
pour les personnes réellement persécutés
et accueille des réfugiés économiques et
les ong alimente la confusion nous
n'avons pas les moyens d'accueillir les
migrants économiques seules les
personnes réellement persécutés devrait
être temporairement accueilli voilà ce
que nous dit laurent papa pas seulement
c'est à dire qu'il ya un moment donné
l'immigration elle vient dieu de pas la
part des familles da par des étudiants
de la part des gens qui demandent un
travail donc c'est au niveau de ces
trois flux là qu'il faut agir avec ce
que propose d'ailleurs xavier bertrand
c'est une solution de quotas de façon à
ce que ray on puisse réguler nous mêmes
aussi bien les regroupements familiaux
que les quotas étudiants que les visas
pour travailler aujourd'hui c'est
quarante mille personnes qui demande à
rentrer sur le territoire pour
travailler est ce que aujourd'hui moi je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec les
chiffres qu'adonis contassot tout à
l'heure sur la partie de travailleurs de
deux travailleurs sans papiers oui il y
à des sociétés il ya des entreprises
aujourd'hui qui utilisent ces sans
papiers ils doivent être contrôlés il ya
des contrôles sociaux évidemment on doit
lutter contre ces filières clandestines
mais tout à l'heure on parlait de la
frontière les accords du touquet il faut
aussi les dénoncer c'est pas à la france
de garder la frontière du royaume uni
surtout pas dans les conditions
actuelles et on voit bien que c'est une
inspiration aujourd'hui ce qui s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé on en parlait
tout à l'heure c'est absolument
scandaleux et on est en train de faire
de la manche un cimetière marin comme on
a fait de la méditerranée un cimetière
marin on peut pas laisser faire ça et
c'est aussi de notre responsabilité on
va prendre jean didier berthault tous
les problèmes là l'un après l'autre yves
contassot déjà sur le droit d'asile
comme nous le disait ce téléspectateur
confusion entre droit d'asile réfugiés
politiques réfugiés économiques vous
êtes d'accord avec ça où tout le monde
est à traiter avec la la même égalité je
rajoute donc jean didier berthault et
les républicains qui propose une
immigration choisie ça fait d'ailleurs
longtemps que cette idée est un petit
peu sur la table
écoutez c'est pas très sérieux parce que
il comprit j'entends parler l'ensemble
quasiment des candidats a l'air de faire
un référendum d'abord il serait
probablement
très probablement non constitutionnels
anticonstitutionnelle les meilleurs
spécialistes glisse ça n'est pas
possible donc déjà une question de
sérieux dans la proche des preuves
deuxième élément le regroupement
familial vous le savez il ya des droits
supranationaux qui ne permettent pas de
faire tout à fait ce qui est proposé
troisième élément les étudiants diviser
par deux le nombre d'étudiants étrangers
qui viennent mais ça veut dire qu'on
aura encore plus d'immigration parce que
ça veut dire que si on n'est pas capable
d'aider un certain nombre d'étrangers à
se former et il retourne pour l'immense
majorité dans leur pays pour aider
justement à ces pays à se construire pas
forcément avec nos règles notamment anti
environnementale mandat ils font un
travail et retourne c'est de
l'investissement
or on sait très bien pour éviter une
partie de l'immigration économique il
faut ces pays la capacité de vivre par
eux mêmes et si on empêche la formation
si on ne veut pas les aider eh bien on
aura encore plus d'immigration
économique donc tout ça n'est pas très
serré upac
dernier point oui sur l'asie l'asile
c'est un droit indiscutable et personne
ne peut le remettre en cause là encore
sauf à sortir d'une fois de plus de ce
qu'est la france non je crois que à un
moment donné je comprends les arguments
on les connaît par coeur les arguments
d'une d'une certaine d'une certaine
gauche qui aujourd'hui privilégient la
filière d'immigration avant même avant
même les français voilà je pense qu'il
faut qu'on
doit laisser dire des choses comme ça je
suis désolé les frontières les français
c'est ce que propose xavier bertrand
c'est la triple frontière c'est à dire
les frontières déjà qu'on puisse avoir
les relations avec les pays d'origine de
l'immigration qui ensuite les frontières
à l'est au niveau de l'europe puis
ensuite la frontière la frontière
nationale sur sur les droits d'asile il
s'agit pas de refuser le droit d'asile
il s'agit de le réformer pour qu' on
puisse avoir déjà un dépôt de droit
d'asile immédiat qu'on ait une semaine
pour demander son droit d'asile et non
pas plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs
mois comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
quand on vient d'un pays et qu'on est
persécuté c'est tout de suite qu'on
demande de droit d'asile et qu'ensuite
la l'instruction soit fait aussi
rapidement qu'on puisse les contrôler et
qu'on puisse aussi avoir des empreintes
digitales pour savoir aussi où vont ces
gens comment comment aujourd'hui il
s'intègre aussi dans sur notre
territoire est ce qu'ils vont apprendre
le français enfin je veux dire on a
quand même le droit c'est quand même pas
un gros mot de dire que on a aujourd'hui
où on ne parlait tout à l'heure pour le
pool pour le logement et pour un certain
nombre de sujets le fait de dire que les
français aujourd'hui souffrent il faut
déjà trouver des solutions pour les
français que l'immigration soit un
complément un certain nombre de
problématiques qu'elles soient
nécessaires on l'a vu notamment sur des
étudiants et sur des étudiants et sur
des filières de haute
enfin on va dire d'une d'une
particularité très très important de
qu'on puisse le faire oui mais on peut
plus continuer à ouvrir les vannes comme
c est ensuite à gérer des problèmes ça
n'est plus possible je vois
transnationales ont débordé
on va vous laisser un bond mais il ya un
mais sa jument qui va dans le sens de
jean didier berthault nous avons du mal
à donner une vie décente à celles et
ceux qui que nous avons déjà accueilli
comment pourrais-je être encore d'accord
en faire venir d'autres alors que la
situation est catastrophique
c'est en substance que nous admirent
janvier est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
sur la préférence nationale monsieur
cantat somme m'attaque sur la préférence
social qu'est ce qu'il ya dans des sens
de dire qu'on prenne enfin qu il ya une
préférence nationale et qu'on défend son
pays c'est quoi la décence mais non mais
je nomme je note jean didier berthault
que les propos de marine le pen qui
était stigmatisée par l'énergie ont
encore six à huit mois sont maintenant
repris par les lier jo le note c'est
tout je le note la préférence nationale
qui est illégal elle était dans le
programme d'ouverture lionel dans celui
de marine le pen monsieur porté par les
rebelles évolution elle était dans celui
du rpr avant d'être dans celui de marine
le pen bien avant et bah c'est pas c'est
pas une fierté de notre part de dire ça
yves contassot justement cet argument il
revient quand même souvent dans la
bouche de certains français je vais pas
vous rappeler les sondages
vous additionnez les scores justement de
marine le pen et ray et des exams our
par exemple quand on cette musique qui
dit voilà on n'a pas déjà les moyens
d'accueillir correctement ceux qui sont
déjà là pourquoi on accueillir d'autres
qu'est ce que vous répondez vous chez
yannick jadot chez les verts mais c'est
simple c'est une question de choix
c'est une question de moyens
effectivement qu'on met ou pas au
service des plus faibles des plus
démunis de ceux qui sont dans la misère
on l'a vu tout à l'heure avec votre
reportage c'est une question évidemment
d'investissements quand on dit et qu'on
voit que les plus pauvres voisins en
corse à couvrir tandis que les plus
riches s'enrichissent encore plus on l'a
vu au cours des deux dernières années
mes cd question de choix politique c'est
pas des questions de moyens la france a
largement les moyens financiers
économiques sociaux efforts de régler la
question de la pauvreté régler la
question des plus démunis mais
simplement il n'y a pas cette volonté
alors la droite le fait depuis toujours
en disant oui il faut favoriser
une certaine classe sociale parce que
c'est celle qui votent pour nous mais
bon on l'entend mais c'est un choix
politique ne disons pas qu'on ne peut
pas le faire jean didier berthault et ça
sera le mot de la fin vous êtes encore
avec des vieilles références yves
contassot parce que ça fait bien
longtemps que les classes populaires
justement elles se sont rapprochées de
la droite parce que la gauche ne les
défends plus et justement non en règle
d'or donne règles plus les sujets pas
ceci parce que quand on quand on est
confronté le nombre réel problématique
bah vous le savez on est tous on a tous
été élu local moi quand je voyais le
sujet sur le logement tout à l'heure ça
me rappelle ce que je connais moi dans
mon arrondissement à un moment donné où
on voit un moment donné des situations
qui sont plus tolérables voilà donc on
peut plus faire face à ces situations là
et on est au glee sur 10
vous disiez que vous disiez qu'on a les
moyens je vous disais on a les moyens
mais que vous disiez qu'on a les moyens
d'ouvrir les vannes et de continuer à
ouvrir les vannes comme on l'a fait
depuis des années on le voit bien que ça
n'est plus aussi réussir son voisin qui
a des fraudes qui sont de plus en plus
importante et qu'aujourd'hui les
français ne le tolère plus donc soit on
laisse les choses à la dérive comme
celle ci et on fera comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure le lit des
extrêmes soit on prend les choses en
main on reprend le contrôle sur nos
frontières on reprend le contrôle sur un
certain nombre de décisions qu'on peut
prendre au sein de notre pays et on
arrivera à rétablir un ordre républicain
parce que je pense que notre idéal il
est tout cela c'est qu'un ordre
républicain soit rétablie avec avec ce
discours là nicolas sarkozy ne serait
pas français eric ciotti serait par
concept dont non ne seraient pas
français parce qu'effectivement ils ont
bénéficié du droit à l'immigration alors
et personne ne le voit que et versailles
de l'enquêté
mais oui vous regretté que nicolas
sarkozy ait pu devenir français mais de
notre personne a défendu une immigration
zéro on la défend d'une immigration
maîtrisée et une reprise en main leur
donnant non vous utilisez les
instrumentaliser cette question qui
d'ailleurs pas une des priorités dans
aucune enquête d'opinion cette question
arrive en tête très elle arrive en prêt
à peu près en 10e position mais vous en
fait un enjeu majeur a fait part de sa
diffusion c'est le sujet du débat donc
on parle on parle de
la présidentielle il compte à son nom
mais pas du tout de même si les cinq
premiers mais elle apparaît dans tous
les sondages vous invite quand même
voilà mission en 10e position oui tout
dépend désendetter d'opinion mais merci
en tout cas quasiment toutes les études
d'opinion ça arrive très loin dans les
priorités merci et c'est les questions
environnementales
merci yves contassot merci jean di
liberto d'avoir aidé ou en direct sur m6
les français c'est la fin de cette
émission rendez vous demain dès 20
heures n'oubliez pas de réagir dessine à
être commentée posez vos questions sur
le conte telegraph berthet france
l'actualité continue tout l'aspect
remercier m
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès